the action-packed new trailer for red
notice has been revealed what yes really
come on what hold on a second
don't even you're an actor
what camera are you on this campus what
i don't believe you for a half a second
but you don't know that this dwayne
johnson ryan reynolds gal gadot are in
this movie
being a a close personal friend
confidant of dwayne johnson
i imagine the first thing
that happened when your dwayne johnson
notification went off on your phone
because you have your how do you know
what's up for notifications that you're
like i gotta watch this trailer
child life don't bother me right now
come on i'm watching dwayne
it's so good it's so good so here's
what's going on in the movie okay um
ryan reynolds is like the second
greatest art thief in the world right
gagado is the best art thief in the
world
right um dwayne johnson is an fbi agent
and ryan reynolds and dwayne john's got
to go team up that's right whole thing
do this whole thing that's right so i i
imagine you would have been all over
this trailer of course okay i'm obsessed
i can't wait for this movie to come out
it's gonna be funny it's gonna it's
gonna be everything you know what we
should have like our viewers watch it
with us we should have a watch party we
should
we should have a watch party that's a
great idea well we're gonna we're having
kind of a watch yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna have a trailer watch part i want
to show you the full trailer everybody
um sankey is gonna try and contain her
glee and uh you just give us your
reactions you know when we come back
nolan booth
the second most wanted art thief in the
world
special agent john hartley
fbi
hi guys
how'd you find me you stole william
strang's lady with the red hat from the
tape you can't hurt that with me
[Music]
i got that on etsy
[Music]
i want you to help me catch the most
wanted art thief in the world
the
bishop
hello boys it's so nice to finally meet
you in person
[Music]
she set me up
frame me
a few clever keystrokes
john hartley
she's gonna steal cleopatra's eggs
they're priceless we catch her together
i can clear my name and i'll help you
become the number one thief in the world
again lift with your neck even if i did
partner up with you
you still only have one brain
what's your plan son of a [ __ ]
see
easy peasy
you have to be the two dumbest man on
the planet you look
awful third
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
this is
are you kidding me what this is hard
are you not entertained
[Music]
casting a thief can be dangerous
if i'm seeing some
i'm seeing some indiana jones in there
i'm seeing some true lies in there with
that dance scene
um and there's a small group of people
that will agree with me i'm seeing some
of the rundown in there which is still
maybe one of my favorite dwayne johnson
movies
of all time this is not bad things for
me to be comparing them to comparing
this trailer to like those movies i'm
just saying you're just saying i know i
think it's gonna be so much fun it's
gonna be a ride just it's gonna be so
much fun ryan reynolds in it it's gonna
be amazing and gal gadot who's kick ass
i'm gonna take a quick video johnson
okay um who who really wants this watch
party who really wants this watch party
and we'll we'll see we should totally
hands up hands up if you want the watch
party and you get to watch it with me
that's right you're just screaming over
it the entire time i'd probably be
standing the whole time and you know i i
could get loud i can get loud while
watching this is a great this is a great
i remember when this was first announced
i was like obviously this is going to be
great it's three of them together it's
gonna be great right you know there's
certain movies where you just just
expect fun yep this is the movie that is
fun right and dwayne johnson again
invincible apparently
who's like getting hit by a bull
like that i mean he could take a bull we
know that in real life you can take a
bowl well he's probably going to take a
start off and show him the tattoo
there's a brahma bowl tattoo and the
bull's gonna be like i got you never
mind we're cool
i can't wait